hey guys how's it going so i'm pretty
excited because my show on aol hardwired
2.0 this is the second season the first
episode just went live so i'm gonna be
hanging out in the comments all day and
i will put a link in the description
where you guys can go check it out and
in this video i'm gonna give you a
little 30 second trailer of the show
i'm ijustine and my life completely
revolves around technology it's really a
super stealthy recording device let's do
it
they figured out a way to use 3d
printing to build a replacement for the
human skull
we're now able to monitor our own brain
waves and have fun in the process this
is awesome
eye tracking glasses i'm wearing will
tell me how effective a soldier i can
actually be i'd like a replay of my
victory
i've always wanted to be a superhero so
this is real life
there's my hands oh god
he's touching me this is absolutely
insane is this even legal what is next
the fact that one day all of these
activities are going to be used to
improve our lives is pretty empowering
join me as i explore the most
revolutionary wearable tech on the
planet what's better than that
what i'm most excited about is i
absolutely love technology if you guys
are new here well even if you are new
here you're probably already well aware
of that so doing the show has been so
amazing because i've got to talk to so
many cool people
excuse excuse me i'm filming car horn go
really cool places do really neat things
and i get to kind of put it all into a
really well produced show which is
something that i can't do myself you
guys have probably seen on my instagram
oh my hashtag hardwired and a lot of you
guys are like what are you even talking
about what are you doing well this is
what i've been doing so head over to the
link in the description so you guys can
check out the first episode first
episode is about food tech the second
one is about performance tech and i'm
really upset because uh i accidentally
formatted an sd card that had all of my
vlog footage so you guys could have had
some behind the scenes stuff guess what
i deleted it
it was one of those things like as i saw
it was being deleted i was like
like my life just flashed before my eyes
well actually my life didn't but that
whole day of stuff that we did flashed
before my eyes as i saw my card being
formatted and i was like that emoji it
was like that was this emoji right there
that was me that
was me anyway i hope you guys enjoyed
the first episode there'll be new
episodes out every wednesday and don't
forget to leave some comments because i
will be commenting back to you guys all
day and also if you have nothing else to
say just tell me what your favorite food
is see you later bye